[MUSIC PLAYING]
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Did you know Android has built
in anti-virus protection that
gets more powerful every second?
It starts when an Android
developer uploads their app
to Google Play.
A self-learning at-risk
analyzer scans and simulates
apps, looking for
potential security issues.
If there's an issue, the app
won't appear in Google Play.
On Android devices,
Verify Apps regularly
scans for harmful behavior,
warning users, and then sending
this information
to the analyzer,
so it keeps getting smarter.
SafetyNet also scans devices
for exploits and network
vulnerabilities, protecting more
than one billion devices daily
and, again, sending data
back to the analyzer
to get more powerful.
Android and Google Play--
constantly making your
mobile device safer at home,
work, and everywhere in between.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
EDWARD CUNNINGHAM:
Well, good afternoon.
I hope the video has given you a
clue as to which session you're
in.
So this talk is going to
be about Google security
services for Android.
My name is Edward Cunningham,
and I'm a project manager
on the Android security team.
So I hope that some of you may
have caught the talk yesterday
by Adrian Ludwig, who leads
Android security, talking
about the overview
of Android security
and its position
in the ecosystem.
If you didn't catch
that, I recommend
going and checking out the
video that will be online.
But I'll begin with a bit
of an introduction that
helps frame Google's services
for Android security fit-in.
And there'll be lots of time
at the end for questions,
so I hope we can have
a good discussion.
Android has become a part of
the fabric of our daily lives,
and nearly all of us
interact with Android
in some form each
day, whether that's
through the phone you use--
85% of smartphones
are Android phones--
or, perhaps, the phone of
someone you communicate with,
or maybe the TV you have--
that could be running Android--
or the point of sale system that
you use in a store you visit.
And securing all of these
devices and different use cases
is what many of us at Google
on the Android security team
get excited by each
day as our mission.
But it's not just Google's job.
Insuring and driving the
security of this ecosystem
is something that is performed
by our partners, OEMs,
enterprises, and developers
too, so improving
the security of
this vast ecosystem
is an exciting challenge.
In this talk, I'm going to
give you an insight into some
of Google's many services
for Android security
and give specific
examples of ways
that you could take
advantage of these services.
The Android ecosystem
consists of many millions
of devices and apps and
use cases, but at its core,
consists of the
people who use them.
Android likely has
the most diverse set
of users of any
computing platform today.
And the range of threats
that they encounter
drives their security models
and the protections we
put in place.
At one end of the spectrum,
we have those who face,
perhaps, the most advanced
adversaries, the likes
of world leaders, who are
investing hundreds of thousands
of dollars to protect
their communications.
And last year, we had
that President Obama
had started using Android
phone for his presidential
communications.
And his successor appears
to have done likewise.
But of course, Android
security can't just
be about those who can afford
to pay a premium for security.
Android phones are
a critical lifeline
for many of the most oppressed
groups and persecuted people
in the world today,
such as refugees,
who could be fleeing
from oppressive regimes.
Android brings them a way
to communicate, to navigate,
and it includes powerful
security protections
for those who can't afford
to pay an extra dollar, euro,
or pound for that security.
Another example where the
security guarantees in Android
are driving new
businesses and use cases
is in the realm of gaming.
Scenes like you
see in the middle
here were common last summer
when the Pokemon Go phenomenon
kicked off.
The core of Pokemon
Go's business model
is a sophisticated approach
to detecting abuse,
and many other games
rely on this similarly.
Specifically, Pokemon Go
uses Google's APIs on Android
to detect fraudulent
uses and devices,
who would be performing
fraud in their game.
And you'll have seen
at the talk yesterday
that all Android devices
have a common set of security
properties.
This is what we describe
as the platform security.
This is built into the
Android open source
project, the foundational
layers of security.
This includes things like
application isolation.
The key part of this
is the sandboxes
that protect apps, make
sure the data inside apps
is for the app to use only,
and that another app can't
peer into the data
from any other app.
Device integrity is important.
Features like
verified boot ensure
the integrity of
the system partition
with cryptographic checks.
And data encryption,
full disk encryption,
makes sure the data,
user data, is protected.
Android has advanced
exploit mitigation features,
things like address space
layout randomization or integer
overflow protection
ensure that it's
hard to exploit vulnerabilities
in the platform,
even if they are present.
And lastly, management
capabilities--
Android has built
powerful capabilities,
such as work profiles
or administrative APIs
to allow you to manage devices.
This is obviously
important in being
able to deploy Android
devices in many different use
cases, such as your enterprise.
So across all modern
Android phones,
there's a relatively
uniform set of capabilities.
In fact, it could be said
that across Android and iOS
and Chrome OS, all
modern mobile operating
systems, that set of
capabilities is pretty similar.
And this is how the
future of cloud computing
is being shaped.
Android is-- one of the key
parts of Android, I guess,
is the research
community around it.
Being an open source
program, we have
hundreds of researchers,
developers around the world
contributing to that security.
Last year, Android's
vulnerability rewards program
paid out over a million
dollars to researchers.
And as we build this ecosystem
of research and development
around Android security,
we're bringing Android
to new heights of
security as we grow
this protection year on year
through the platform releases.
On top of this solid
foundation, Google
builds security services
to protect users
from the risks they might face.
Building services on top of
platforms is at Google's core.
Like Google wasn't originally
a platform provider,
and so this is something
that's being built into Android
from the very first minute.
And this is where
SafetyNet comes in.
SafetyNet is the
collection of services
that Google builds
and freely deploys
to protect users and
keep the ecosystem safe.
Our mission is to
protect Android users
with data-driven security
apps and services.
And this is what we're going
to look at in this session.
We provide comprehensive
endpoint protection
out of the box.
From the very first moment a
user starts using their device,
they should have all the
necessary protections in place
to be and feel safe.
The out of the box part
is very important to us.
We don't think a
user should ever
need to go and invest
more money in security
once they've got their device.
It's a fundamental
part of Android.
It would be sad if you'd gone
and paid $100, $200, even more
for your phone, but
then feel the need
to pay $10 every
month to get security.
But what we have here with
SafetyNet offers that built in.
So SafetyNet broadly
maps into four segments,
and this roughly forms
the agenda for this talk.
And then we're going to look
at some of these in detail.
First, Verify Apps, and this
is what most people's minds
jumped to when they think about
Google's security services
for Android.
This is in the realm of harmful
app detection, prevention,
and removal.
I'll show you some new features
in Verify Apps and even
some APIs, too,
that you could use.
Then we have the sensor network,
which is rather more elusive.
and this is our
privacy-preserving security,
analytics, and telemetry
framework built
into every Android device.
This is how we can see
across the Android ecosystem,
the health of Android devices.
It allows us to monitor
the behavior of apps
and see when things
step out of line.
And when something unusual
happens on a device,
we can use this sensor network
to root cause that change,
and then go and remediate
where we are able.
The sensor network observes
things like critical security
settings, device
integrity, and hundreds
of other signals,
which we'll look at,
and I'll show you some examples
of how that's interpreted.
Next is SafetyNet
developer APIs,
and this is an area
we've been investing
in a lot in the last year.
We want to provide
ways for all developers
to interrogate the state
of security devices.
It's all well and
good for us to say
Android is secure, but
actually for an app or any code
running on the device to be
able to make good decisions
about that is important.
And this is getting more and
more important every year.
As we see, many of
the critical decisions
related to security being
taken not just at the operating
system level, but at
the application level,
so I'll cover three different
APIs in this session, which
I think could be of value.
And last, we have
Android Device Manager.
If I was to rank these four
in order of importance,
this would clearly
be at the top.
This is addressing
the largest risk
Android users face when
it comes to security,
and that risk is, of
course, losing a phone.
While we spend a
lot of time, and we
will in this talk,
thinking about harmful apps
or those sort of
attacks, the reality
is that the average
Android user will never
encounter one of these.
But nearly every Android
user will at some point
misplace, lose, or have
their phone stolen.
So we need to have a
tool to help users out
in that occasion.
So Android Device Manager is
our tool to offer peace of mind
in their time of need.
And I'll show you a
little bit about that
towards the end of the talk.
So the good news about
all of these features
is that they are available
across most active Android
devices.
There's no need to have a new
version of Android to use them.
They're built on
top of the platform.
They're deployed through Google
Play Services and the Google
Play Store.
And they are
constantly updating.
So I hope this
comes as good news
that users don't need to be
buying a new phone to get
these protections.
In fact, a lot of the
work we do is making sure
that users who are running
older versions of the operating
system, potentially ones that
aren't receiving security
updates, will still get
the core protections.
Here's the scale at
which we operate.
We're protecting over 1.4
billion devices all the time.
The unique thing
about SafetyNet is
that we have an unparalleled
view into the Android ecosystem
to spot when things go wrong
and to offer protection.
We spot anomalies, and we can
see trends that are emerging.
We scan devices
pretty rigorously.
We're currently at about 750
million device scans a day.
If I was to have given this
talk a couple of months ago,
that number would
have been 400 million.
We're ramping up
very aggressively.
And I'll show you how
that works in a bit.
But let's begin by
talking about apps.
We're scanning over six
billion of them daily.
The Google Play Store is
a cornerstone of security
for the Android ecosystem.
Google Play allows users to get
the most out of their devices
by getting apps that they want
to use to enable communication
or games and so forth.
And it's also enabling new
business models for developers,
giving them access
to a vast audience
of potential consumers.
With over a million apps on
Google Play and 65 billion
downloads, ensuring the safe
distribution of these apps
is imperative.
So this diagram describes
at a very high level
the security lifecycle overlap
that is distributed via Play.
So we begin in the
top left, where
apps arrive on the Play Store.
This is where a
developer will upload
an app in the form
of an APK file
to the Google Play
Developer Console.
To have been able to
do this, the developer
will have had to sign up
for a publisher account.
They'll have accepted the
Play developer distribution
agreement, and they will have
to pay a registration fee.
and for that registration
to have been verified,
details from the Google
account that was used
and billing information
will have been used
to process that registration.
So once the app's uploaded,
before it is actually
published, it passes through
our comprehensive review
and an analysis pipeline.
The first step of this
is manual policy review.
And every app that's
published to Google Play
is manually reviewed by a
human for policy inspection.
So at this point,
we'll look to see,
does the app adhere to
Google Play policies?
And we'll check
it doesn't contain
violating content,
things like spam
or illegal content
or impersonation.
So once it's passed
through, and it's
got past that part
of the check, we then
enter our security analysis part
of the pipeline, which is where
automated analysis kicks in.
This is in the realm of things
like inspecting the code that's
inside the app, the
file is contained,
and also running the app
[INAUDIBLE] emulators.
I'll give you an in-depth
look at what that looks
like in a couple of slides.
So this analysis is
performed on all the apps,
and it passes to
our score engine.
And the score engine
is really what
makes a decision about whether
the app is good or bad.
Either the score engine
notices some behavior,
which is in line with known
bad behavior, in which case
the app will be rejected,
or sometimes it's
not sure about the app.
It sees something
suspicious, and then we
pass it for another
round of manual review.
And at this point, we end up
in manual security review.
This is where it's passed
to an expert in app security
analysis.
And they will go
and review that app,
and then make a determination,
either rejecting or approving
it.
And the decisions that are
taken by those human analysts
feed back into
the score engine's
future decision-making.
So once it's got through
this part of the flow,
we end up all being well, as
is the case for 99% of apps
in the published state.
Sometimes there are cases where
we've spotted vulnerabilities
in the app that aren't
intentionally harmful.
Perhaps the developer has
included a vulnerable version
of a library.
An example of that
would be if you include
a version of open SSL
that's old and it's
vulnerable to the Logjam attack.
So we would actually
in this pipeline also
expose to the developer
in the Developer Console
the information about
that app and say, hey,
you should probably
go and fix this issue.
There are numerous
such vulnerabilities
that we will alert
developers to.
So this process is
paralyzed, meaning
that most apps going from
upload to the published state
get there in just a
couple of hours or less.
But it doesn't end there.
Every app is
constantly resubmitted
through this pipeline,
being reanalyzed
and rescored every day.
And the score engine
is augmented with data
from the sensor network.
This is what I referred
to in the previous slide,
where the sensor network
in Android devices
is reporting back how
those apps are behaving.
So you can think
about it, where we
have the dynamic
sort of analysis
happening in
Google's Cloud, where
we're emulating these apps.
We actually have a lot of data
coming back from real devices
running as apps.
We also have Verify
Apps, so if an app
is determined to be
harmful, Verify Apps
operating on devices makes sure
that no instances of that app
are installed.
It'll warn users about the
app if it's installed already.
It'll prompt them to uninstall.
And Verify Apps prevents
the app from being
installed if it's distributed
outside of Play as well.
And this is where it
gets really exciting,
because this process
for Google Play
is actually applied
mostly, as I've
shown here, for apps that we
find outside of Google Play
too.
In fact, over 90% of
apps that are installed
from unknown sources
or preloaded app
stores or any other source have
passed through our security
analysis pipelines.
So I've alluded to harmful apps.
I thought it would be worth us
thinking about what actually
is a harmful app.
At Google, we use the term,
Potentially Harmful Apps,
to talk about apps that we
consider harmful in Android.
And a potentially
harmful app is an app
that poses a potential
security risk to users,
their device, or their data.
And we see these broken down
into two main categories--
those that abuse APIs
and those that exploit
vulnerabilities in the platform.
With API abuse, we see
apps that use Android APIs.
They operate within the
Android security model
to perform a behavior that
could be considered harmful.
An example of this
would be a phishing app.
Most phishing apps aren't
exploiting the platform.
They're using standard
Android APIs and UI widgets
to draw a convincing-looking
login screen
to phish for credentials.
And this category of app
in the realm of API abuse
is by far the most common.
Over 90% of PHAs that we
see are in the realm of API
abuse and social engineering.
The other category would
be described as exploits.
This is where you're taking
advantage of a gap or a hole
that has been
unpatched in Android.
An example of this
would be rooting,
where people root their device,
or privilege escalation,
where you might break outside
of the application sandbox
in some other way.
And this is less common,
as I say-- fewer than 10%.
And if you're running an Android
device that has got the latest
security patches, typically,
these sorts of PHAs
are ineffective.
Nearly every PHA we see
is trying to make money
in some way, and so
it's frankly much
simpler to do that
as a malware offer
by going down the
API abuse path.
And the unique thing
about our security team
is that, of course,
we're not just
looking at what's going wrong
and then trying to go and catch
those apps, but we're
able to effect change
in the Android platform.
So when we see API abuse, we
can go and improve the APIs
in the future
versions of Android.
An example of that would be
we'd seen quite a lot of malware
that abuses the
device admin APIs
to try and take
the device hostage,
prevent themselves
from being uninstalled.
And so in Android N, there were
some improvements to those APIs
to remove that
sort of behavior it
that was being commonly abused.
So with that in mind, I'll
now dive into more detail
here about this app analysis.
This is really looking at the
core of our app risk analyzer.
I'll talk about just a
few of the specifics,
so we begin with
static analysis.
This is where we go and
essentially decompile the app,
look at the static
code, and we match
that against the known patterns
that are considered harmful.
We extract features
and just look
at everything that's
contained within the APK file.
The next part, dynamic analysis,
is a lot more exciting.
This is where we run the
applications in our emulators.
Every app we get hold
of runs in our emulators
in the cloud in a real
Android environment.
This is how we detect
behavior that couldn't be seen
through static analysis alone.
We monitor things like
network connections
or interaction
with other services
on the device to come to a
determination about behavior
that could be
considered harmful.
I mentioned third
party reports here.
We would never
claim that we were
catching 100% of all bad apps.
We're always trying
to improve it.
And one of the things
that the Android security
team has built
out is very active
relationships with the
research community,
as well as being provided
with information that helps
us improve this detection.
So we have academic
institutions,
security companies,
independent researchers,
who are all tipping
us off about new types
of bad apps they find.
We build the protections
into this analyzer service.
And so fostering
those relationships
is very important.
Developer relations,
developer relationships--
this is where, of
course, when we see apps,
either through Play or
even outside of Play,
we try and map the link
between those developers.
Through Play, it's, of
course, a little bit easier,
because we have Google
accounts, and we'll try and find
the relationships between
those accounts, other activity
they've performed on
Google properties,
and we find the
link between apps.
Even outside of Play,
features of the app,
such as the signing certificate
or even the structure
of the app itself give
us a clue as to the link
between developers and
helps us incriminate apps
based on other apps
from the same developer.
Next, we have the
sensor network,
and this is what I mentioned.
This is the feedback loop
for devices on the field.
This really is the unique
thing about our analysis.
We're really able to augment
what we see with the behavior
apps for real.
This feedback comes
into the risk analyzer
and helps us identify
apps that maybe
weren't exhibiting that harmful
behavior in the emulators.
And similarity analysis--
of course, most harmful apps
we see are not brand new.
They're not unique strategies
that have been taken,
and so we're able to compare
the features of the code
to see if they look like other
ones we've previously flagged.
And we're not doing
this on a whim.
We have 20,000 dedicated
CPUs running 24 hours a day,
seven days a week
operating this pipeline.
Each day, we're analyzing
over half a million apps.
As I mentioned, we get apps
not just from Google Play,
and in the last 30
days, we've crawled apps
from over 100,000
different websites.
And increasingly, we're able to
turn to new forms of analysis.
Machine learning models
operating in our app risk
analyzer have caught
over 50% of harmful apps
that were submitted to Play
in the last month alone.
I'll show you an example
of that later on.
So with that in mind,
what's the end result?
This would be
useless if we didn't
think it was having an effect.
At most conferences in
the technology world,
you're led to expect that
all charts should be going up
and to the right.
So I'm sorry to disappoint
you that this one is
looking rather flat, but
that's for good reason.
Contrary to many of the
reports in the media,
mobile malware is not the next
major threat to civilization.
So this chart shows
the percentage
of Android devices,
which have a known
potentially harmful
app installed
over the last couple of years.
And you'll see at the end
of 2016, we're hovering
and, in fact, declining a
little bit around 0.69%.
So that's less
than 1% of devices
that we've detected have
a potentially harmful app
installed.
And that's the overall PHA
rate for the ecosystem.
We can break it down in many
ways that give us a little bit
more nuance into that figure.
For example, there's huge
geographic variation here.
One of the big focus
areas for our team
has been looking at
PHA campaigns operating
in the Southeast Asia
region, especially
on very low end phones,
where, perhaps, they're
not certified Android devices.
Some of them are even coming
with malware preloaded
on the device out of the store.
And so that's something we're
working really hard to tackle.
In fact, of the uncertified,
unapproved Android devices,
they have a 500% higher chance
of seeing a potentially harmful
app installed.
So if we split into
those users, who
are installing from Google
Play and those who are not
and using other sources, we
see another stark contrast.
The Google Play figure
is the line at the bottom
here, where we see that
just 0.05% of devices
have encountered a
potentially harmful app.
And if you're operating inside a
managed environment, of course,
you can inform where your users
end up on this sort of chart.
You can decide to
restrict your users
to install from the Play Store.
You can even go a
step further if you're
in a managed profile by
using the managed Play
features to restrict the
apps that are available.
So I hope this is reassuring in
that the instances of malware
that we see are
really quite rare.
In the next-- in
a few weeks time,
we're going to be releasing our
2016 annual Android security
year-end review.
so I'd encourage
you to come check
that out, because
actually, it's many more
insights like these and lots
of other data from last year.
So based on having
identified harmful apps,
what actually
happens on devices?
This screen on the
right is what you'd
see if you were
trying to install
a known PHA from
an unknown source
or from a third party store.
As a reminder, of course,
if we detect any PHA,
that app will no
longer be distributed
through Google Play.
So at install time,
a user would never
need to be worried about
installing a harmful app
from the Play Store.
So we verify every
installation that
happens outside of Google Play.
That includes any OEM
store that's pre-loaded,
any carrier store, or
unknown sources that
installs from third
party app stores
that the user might have
downloaded or from file
sharing, peer to
peer, or the web.
And the result of this is that
Verify Apps will either warn,
block, or approve the install.
This dialog is showing what
happens when we warn to user.
There are some types
of harmful apps
that we allow the user to
proceed with the installation.
In fact, if you were to
click More Details here,
you'd see there is a button that
allows you to go and install
the app.
And sometimes we
get asked, well,
why do we allow users
to install harmful apps?
And the answer to that is that
not every potentially harmful
app is not wanted by the user.
The most clear
example of that would
be rooting apps, where there
are some number of Android users
who would like to try and root
their device to try and get
new capabilities.
And so our warning dialogs
are mindful of that.
We're not restricting that sort
of behavior in the ecosystem.
We perform a lot of US
experiments with these dialogs.
In fact, we
reshuffled the screen
that you see here at the end
of 2015 to hide that Install
Anyway button under
the More Details,
and we instantly
saw a 50% reduction
in the number of harmful
apps being installed.
So we are trying very
hard to make sure
that users do the right thing.
And we're not just
warning on apps
that we know to be harmful.
Sometimes we'll have
other clues that
help us identify whether this
install might be of concern.
An example of that
would be if we
know it's been installed by
an unusual UID, a Linux UID--
it's not coming from
an app or process
that we expect to have the
permission to install an app.
Or maybe we see the
install being triggered
by another harmful app.
We would warn the
user in that case.
And to give you
a sense of scale,
you might be wondering, how
often do we show these things?
So I looked up the numbers.
For the length of time that I'm
talking today, for yesterday,
at the same time of day, we
showed 1,000 of these warnings
to people in the US.
So it is not
disproportionately large,
but I hope that gives you an
idea of how frequently we're
having to warn
about harmful apps.
On the flip side of Verify
Apps is the periodic scans.
All installed apps,
regardless of origin,
are routinely checked for PHAs.
When we find a PHA, we
put it into the stop state
and make sure the app
isn't running anymore.
And then we either warn the
user or remove the app entirely.
And this notification
on the right
is what happens when we
warn a user about a PHA
that's been found.
There's an Uninstall
button there,
or they can tap for the
notification to find out more.
And uninstalling
PHAs is made easy
by the application sandbox.
The fact that apps are contained
within an application sandbox
means that uninstalling apps
is not a very complicated task.
We're able to very cleanly
remove them from devices.
For the last year
and a half, we've
been scanning every device
in Russia daily for PHAs.
That was to tackle some
very persistent SMS
forward campaigns, and we saw
a huge improvements in the PHA
rates for Russia in doing so.
And so we're excited at
the start of this year
to now be expanding that
coverage to every Android
device in the world.
So every device will be
checking for installed PHAs
daily in just a few weeks time.
And so Verify Apps
isn't just operating
there behind the scenes without
you knowing as an application
developer.
So I'm excited to show
you some new APIs that
are coming in the forthcoming
release of Google Play Services
that you could inspect for
the state of Verify Apps
and take control.
So we have an API called
isVerifyAppsEnabled.
It essentially does
what it says on the tin.
Verify Apps is
enabled by default
for anyone who signs
into an Android device
with a Google account or
uses the Google Play Store.
And for anyone who doesn't fall
into either of those groups,
but who side loads apps,
installs from unknown sources,
they'll be prompted to enable
Verify Apps at each time
that they install.
So you can check if
Verify Apps is enabled.
If not, you can call the
enableVerifyApps API.
That will prompt the user
to enable Verify Apps.
And we have the
listHarmfulApps API.
That will tell you about
any known harmful apps
a user has willingly
installed on that device.
I'll give you a code
example in a second.
I'll mention, finally, that
today already, the platform
has a restriction that you
can put in place if you are
able to use the
DevicePolicyManager
APIs for a managed device to
ensure that Verify Apps is
enabled.
That forces Verify
Apps to be turned on.
The user couldn't choose
to go and turn it off.
So this is the
listHarmfulApps API.
It's incredibly
straightforward to use,
and it removes the need for
you to necessarily build
your own hacky solutions based
on blacklisting, package names,
or other sort of app
matching or sending
that back to your server.
A use case here
you could consider
is if your enterprise
app, you might
want to be auditing for any
harmful apps that are installed
on users' devices.
So you could call this API
and send the results back
to your server.
As I mentioned, this API is
part of Google Play Services,
and you will use it by
connecting to the SafetyNet API
client through the
Google API classes.
So it returns the
time of the last scan
with the last scan
time function.
That'll always be within
the last 24 hours.
We ensure that when you're
calling this API that that
is a fresh scan available.
If for some reason, Verify Apps
was not enabled, of course,
at this stage, you
could then go and call
the enableVerifyApps API to
make sure it was turned on.
And then we have
getHarmfulAppsList.
This is a very
underwhelming API call.
99.5% of the time, it will
return absolutely nothing
at all.
It'll be an empty list,
but let's take a look
at what happens if there
was to be something there.
So there's a list of
harmful apps data objects,
and it contains
information about an app
to identify the harmful one.
You can send this back to
your server, for example.
So first, we have a category.
And this is used to define
what type of harmful app it is.
An example of this could be
phishing or Trojan or SMS fraud
or rooting.
We published our
classifications of PHAs online.
You can search for
our white paper,
and it's also documented
in the API documentation.
And then to identify
the specific app,
we include the package
name of the app,
as well as the Sha256#
of the APK file.
And then we include an
example at the bottom
here of what that
could look like.
Here we have a phishing app and
its package name and digest.
The digest is a way of uniquely
identifying that APK file.
So with that covered, let's
talk about the sensor network.
I think this is one of
the more exciting parts,
because it operates
so behind the scenes,
people don't typically
know about it.
So I'm glad to share some
of that with you today.
On the right, you
see a warning dialog
would pop up when a user--
when an app tries to send
a message to a premium rate
SMS number.
We ask the user, do you
really want to send this?
And the responses to
that dialog are fed back
into the sensor network, which
help us to identify apps that
could be performing SMS fraud.
This is one example
of the sort of data
that the sensor
network picks up,
allowing us to
identify bad apps.
So the sensor network
is fundamentally
this feedback loop
that pipes back
into our app risk
analyzer, helping
us to identify new threats.
In a sense, SafetyNet is
looking and keeping an eye
on what happens on our
device after the app
is installed to make sure
it doesn't step out of line.
And the changes in
state on that device
can be attributed back to the
app that was just installed.
There are hundreds of signals.
Some of them are listed here.
For example, exploit attempt
logging, system integrity
checks, SELinux
enforcement, network probes,
which [INAUDIBLE] man
in the middle attacks,
that sort of thing
that, SMS denials,
and the core system
security settings.
So let's see one example.
We perform statistical analysis
on top of this, and, of course,
operating at such huge
scale across over a billion
Android devices allows
us to spot anomalies
when they crop up.
So this is one
scorer that features
in the scorer engine called
the dead or insecure score.
And what this tracks is how
often devices disappear off
our radar once an
app is installed.
Typically, we expect that
when you install an app,
that device should
carry on checking back
in with the sensor
network the next day
and the next day
and the next day.
And so we measure
for each app what
the probability of that device
checking back in the next day
is, and so we look and compare
that with the ecosystem
average.
Of course, there is
some drop-off every day
from normal device usage.
Maybe I'm going to go
and buy a new phone.
But for apps where that differs
significantly from the norm,
we can go and
investigate that app
or very clearly identify
that the app was
doing something anomalous.
And so this is what
we use to go and flag
new apps that cause
devices to go dark,
maybe because they try
and turn off SafetyNet,
or maybe they
break the device so
fundamentally that the user
has to go and factory reset it.
This has been very effective at
detecting new rooting campaigns
that we've looked at, such
as Hummingbad or Ghost Push.
And we published a
blog post about this,
so if you want to go
and search for it,
you can just search for
dead or insecure score.
Of course, we're
not just limited
to conventional
statistical analysis.
Machine learning is playing
an increasingly key role
in how we find harmful apps.
What you see here is
a clustering of apps,
of harmful apps based on their
install patterns generated
with a neural network
using TensorFlow.
This uses the technique
called word embeddings, which
has pioneered in the field of
natural language processing,
but applying it to apps instead.
In a sense, the order in
which apps are installed
is quite similar to the
order in which words
are constructed in sentences.
And so we can use
the ordering an app
installs to discern something
about the apps themselves.
So the result of
this neural network
is a vector for every app.
And app vectors are positioned
in vector space, such that apps
that share common contacts or
attributes or patterns show up
in a similar area
or vector space.
So for example, we'd expect
to find all the messaging apps
showing up in one part of vector
space or all of the gaming apps
in another cluster.
And this is true for PHAs too.
So in this 2D embedding,
you see here we've
colored in all of the
potentially harmful apps
and their different categories.
And you see that they cluster
in sometimes quite tight groups.
For example, in the top left,
we have a light blue section.
Those are all SMS fraud apps.
So hopefully, you
can see how we're
able to use this very
powerfully to detect
new types of harmful
behavior for a new app
that we haven't yet
been able to classify.
If we see that it's embedding,
and vector space shows up
within that cluster, we
can begin to highly suspect
that app is also being part
of an SMS fraud campaign.
Approaches like these are
greatly improving our ability
to detect new types of harm.
So let's take a look
at the attestation API.
This is one of the
most frequent APIs
that I discussed with
enterprises and developers.
I think it could be
powerful to use maybe
for some of your use cases too.
This screen here
shows Android Pay
deciding that it hasn't been
able to determine the device
security sufficiently
to be able to run.
They use the attestation
API to determine this.
Many apps have
questions, such as,
is the app talking to my server?
Is it actually my app?
Can I trust the platform APIs?
Is it a genuine device?
Is my app running
on a rooted phone?
It is the SafetyNet
attestation API
that allows you to assess the
security and compatibility
of the Android environments in
which your apps are running.
So I'll briefly talk you
through how this works.
At a high level, what happens
is you'll call the attestation
API on a device, and then
we all run through SafetyNet
a series of checks to come to
a decision about the device
state.
The result will come
back from a Google server
as a signed statement
as to the device
integrity and compatibility.
And then you can inspect
that signed statement
on a device you trust--
that's normally your server--
to decide whether or not
you're going to trust
that app or that device.
So you need both client and
server side implementations.
So you begin by calling the
attest method of SafetyNet API,
also in Google Play Services,
with a single use token that
identifies that request.
That token will have
been sent by your server.
And then that's the
end of what you're
going to do on your device.
When you get the result back,
you send that to your server.
As you're using the
attestation to decide
if you trust the
device, you don't
want to be doing any checks
on the device itself.
So now on the server side,
you pass back this result.
It's in the form of
adjacent web signature.
And first, you want
to validate the JWS.
So the first step is validating
the SSL certificate chain
and checking that the leaf
certificate matches what was
issued to you at android.com.
And then you'll verify
that that certificate
was used to sign the JWS.
Now you can look at the
actual contents of the JWS,
which I'm showing
on the right here.
So you'll check
the nonce matches
the one that you requested.
You'll check the
timestamp is acceptably
close to your request time.
And then you can check the
details about the app itself,
so you can check, does the
package name of the app
match my own app?
Does the signing certificate
hash match my own app?
Even does the digest
of the APK file
itself match the
APK that I produced?
And this helps you
determine on your server
whether the Android app that is
talking to you is really yours.
Sometimes we won't include
the APK information,
and that's because we can't
determine with any reliability
that that is your app.
Maybe it's a random
script that is not even
running on Android at all.
And then you can look
at the last two fields.
We have CTS profile match
and basic integrity,
and those are really
the key results here.
CTS profile match
is telling you,
is this device
definitely a device
that has been approved
and certified?
All devices that are
published or produced
with Google services
on them have
to go through some
rigorous certification.
So you can check.
Is it a certified device?
And you can restrict the
operation of your app
to those devices.
And then we have the
basic integrity field,
which is a slightly weaker
check than CTS profile match.
That's now ignoring whether or
not the device was certified
and just checking, does the
basic integrity of this device
look like it is a
compatible real Android
environment that's not being
tampered with in any way?
So we got--
I'll help you out with this,
if you want to go check it out.
I encourage you to
go and see if this
answers some of your
questions that you might have.
Like many apps are using
their own basic rooting
checks or integrity
checks on device,
which are trivially bypassed.
And so SafetyNet attestation
is the solution for that.
We're obviously
paying close attention
to how well was this
working, looking
at researchers who are trying
to bypass such restrictions.
And as far as we can tell,
it's holding up pretty well.
In fact, one of
the challenges you
may face if you're operating
a service that crosses
many different platforms
is that you're always
limited by the
weakest client that is
going to talk to your server.
So we start to see
maybe Android apps that
start to impersonate iOS
apps or Windows apps or web
clients to try and communicate
with your server end points.
Another API that we
expose is Safe Browsing.
Safe Browsing is
a Google service
that's operated for
many years but lets
applications check
whether a given
URL is potentially harmful.
With it, you can check
pages against Safe Browsing
different threat blacklists.
You could warn users before
they click on a link,
or you could prevent users
from sharing unsafe links.
And on the right, you
see the Chrome browser,
which integrates with the
SafetyNet Safe Browsing API
for every URL that
is loaded in Chrome.
And here, they're
warning the user,
because it looks like this
page distributes malware.
The Safe Browsing API
is very straightforward.
It's pretty much the
code I've shown here.
You first have to register
an API key, which you can get
on the Google Cloud console.
And then you call look up URI
with the URL and the threat
types that you are
concerned about.
At the moment, we have
social engineering
and potentially harmful apps.
And then we give
you a result, which
is whether or not that URL
matched any of the known threat
types.
This is a case where
most of the time, you
will also return an empty list,
in which case that's good news.
And the Safe Browsing
API is designed
to be privacy-preserving
and bandwidth-efficient.
The URL that you're checking
with the Safe Browsing API
is never sent off the device.
And so this is a
really great way
of maintaining the
privacy of that link.
We're also frequently
syncing the blacklist
on device in a
very efficient way,
so it's not consuming resources
or bandwidth unnecessarily
for the user.
So last, we're going to jump
to Android Device Manager.
If you haven't used
it, I'd encourage
you to go and check it out.
Android Device
Manager is this tool
that allows you to find, locate,
ring, wipe any Android device.
And it's built into
every Android device
running Google
services by default.
There's no setup needed.
All you need to do is sign
into the Google account,
and that then it's enabled.
It's active.
You don't even have to have an
app installed on your device.
You're able to go and
load it up off the website
or install the Android
app to go and ring,
lock, or erase any devices that
your account is signed into.
And we have integrations
with Google search,
so if you were signed into
your Google account or Google
search, and you go and
search Find My Phone,
we'll show you a one-box result
showing where your phone is.
Or maybe you have an
Android Wear watch,
and you've misplaced your phone,
but you can use your watch
to ring your phone too.
That's all part of
Android Device Manager.
And this works from
Android 2.3 up,
so it's enabled for pretty
much every device that
is active today.
We're locating
hundreds of thousands
of phones every single day.
So with that, that's
brought us to the end
of my survey of all the
components of SafetyNet.
We talked about
Verify Apps, which
is harmful app detection
and removal, the sensor
network, which is
providing security analysis
and telemetry, helping us
to identify harmful apps,
powerful developer
APIs allowing you
to inspect the security of
a device and make decisions,
and Android Device Manager,
lost device protection.
And the exciting
thing about this
is that it's updating
all the time.
Whenever we come and
present what's going on,
there's always
something new to add.
We're working every
day to develop
these and deploy new
versions to offer
better protection to
users without them
having to pay for anything.
So before I take any
questions, just a reminder
that if you're interested
in knowing more about how
either Android or
Chrome or Google Cloud
fits into your
enterprise environment,
you can go and visit this not
particularly easy to pass link
to learn more about our
connected workspace information
and sign up to get
advanced access,
perhaps, to some of
our upcoming reports,
such as the Android
security year review.
With that, I'd like to
thank you for attending,
and I'll be around
for any questions.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]